salut nous sommes mercredi les six
heures du matin c'est le jour d'un
nouveau casse tête pour cet été ici
voulais voir autre chose que des
cassettes activer la cloche je sors
aussi des petites vidéos comme ça bonus
qui peu sauvage alors aujourd'hui on va
jouer avec ce robot qui est bourrée
d'élastiques et d'encoches est le but de
ce robot apparemment c'est d'en faire un
cube parfait voilà de tout bouger pour
en faire un club parfait ça m'a pas
l'air si simple parce qu'il ya des
choses qui sont disproportionnés par
rapport aux autres en plus j'ai de la
chance parce que j'ai un deuxième
cerveau avec moi aujourd'hui
il s'agit de céline au deuxième cerveau
quand il s'agit de castets le genre
c'était philippe roche il ya eu droit à
ce sera toi
breaking news nous avons également un
troisième cerveau puisque jeanne vient
d'arriver aussi puisque tout le monde
pas si signate en avant c'est comme ça
gêne si vous la connaissez pas eh bien
tu étais dans la deuxième vidéo de ma
chaîne voir le 2 janvier 2016 vous mais
l'affichage juste ici et c'est un peu
grâce à toi que j'ai fait des vidéos
le but du jeu aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a
un robot mais ce robot est un casse tête
on est censé pouvoir faire un cube
inclus parfait avec ça ok il ya des
encoches j'ai un peu étudiée quand même
le truc il ya des encoches de partout
avec toujours un élastique on peut
bouger d'encoches une encoche ok ok
alors c'est un cube sous quelle forme
carré triangle plutôt ovale mais je suis
pas sûr c'est un cercle rouge laquelle
famille d'occupants je pense que déjà il
faut il faut il faut qu'on se pose la
question herbe de combien de petits
cubes
il fait sur combien parce que je suis
claire mais ce qu'on est les meilleurs
invités pour cela
c'est en tout cas celle qui est de
passer à terme on est heureux d'inviter
de garder pour à perdre et je pouvais me
ramener de l'aspirateur l'a fait oui je
fais une vidéo en même temps après elle
m'a dit qu'à jeanne karim j'ai fait bien
qu'elle reste aussi en même temps voilà
pour l'instant je sais pas si c'est un
avantage
je pense que ça peut durer très
longtemps soit 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 et je pense que c'est un cube
de 3 sur 3 à trois points c'est correct
[Rires]
je pense que ça fait 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
et ensuite encore au-dessus 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 et en 48 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 ou
voyez là soit un peu comme des lasagnes
louis qui a trois fois c'est qu'un ou
pas du tout non sicile et la jeanne ses
joies bien et le reste absolument mais
c'est vrai non
on peut te soutenir par contre en fait
nous notre but c'est d'en faire un
curetage et compte deux chats donc je
pense qu'en termes de hauteur il va
avoir à trois couches la bouche comme ça
sur trois autres couches puisque
qu'occupa 3 x 3 mètres cubes par surface
aux attentes
c'est parce que moi je suis un petit peu
tu vois j'ai bien tapé bien sûr y être
touché par exemple fameux bien tu vois
non mais humer eut mais la bête alors
alors alors non mais moi je réfléchis où
les pieds je pense que le piège ça va
être la tête du classement parce qu'elle
est décentré elle fait pas la bonne
blague à la vie alors je fais rien du
tout je fais vraiment semblant c'est un
casse-tête à tâtons là par exemple comme
il y en a deux et qu'on sait qu'on va
vouloir faire trop à faire des trucs un
peu comme ça tu vois ce que je veux dire
mais regardez jamais réussi non non mais
ça fait qu attend mais tu vois ce que le
bon là ça marche pas mon histoire ici
attend regarde attend 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3
oui mais faut placer les bras à la
maintenant tu fais n'importe quoi mais
et bien figure toi que peu 4 pins est ce
que ta conscience de ce que je vais
sûrement que oui j'avais quand même
l'impression de tenir un truc là d'un
robot à temps on pourrait être surpris
de deux parce que je tente de la
longueur
alors naturellement je sais pas si je
sais pas mais il viendra renforcer
l'effort vous avez comme la chaîne de
jeanne qui apparaît justement une chute
de nous et hurlant c'est évident tu
viens de le relancer au début de l'été
absolument je relance mais vidée au
début de l'été la france dans la céline
h je me battais céline oui mais je sais
qu'à ses lignes finalement c'est un
petit pas mon prénom
ouais mais c'est pas mal ta chaîne
allemande lachheb en même temps quand
j'ai fait une vidéo avec amics m je dis
pas maxime dynamique sam absolument bon
ça va donc la taille haute la routine
langage youtube j'ai déjà eu quand tu le
dis c'est le langage
alors alors alors déjà c'est pas mal
mais je sais pas si j'ai pas s'il n'a
pas bien c'est non merci je poursuis à
ses yeux y arriver si je pense bien
j'aurai un petit carré je tiens bon
boulot calais salaires la boutique moi
c'est mes dents de vous voir le
manipuler oui le voit tous cas pas à
faire mais reconnaît bien sûr et oui tu
as tu observes pendant ce temps d'accord
mais je commence quand il va le prendre
mal car en deux secondes
non ça je pense pas mais du coup je ça
nous donne des idées quand même là ce
moi qui fais avec mon petit robot tu
sais c'est beau c'est par l'expo contre
j'ai fait un travail de chiens est-ce
que ça est-ce que ça est ce que ces
balades les crottes de chien je mets un
sondage juste ici alors que savannah a
pas de chien est un vrai sondage vous
pouvez voter à cette question bon écoute
moi bien je retente une dernière fois
qui après je pense que je te laisse le
bébé tu vois là en soit là on est pas
mal
le petite fenêtre quoi on n'est pas là
ça fait 4 / 3 / tout donc c'est on est
plus sur un rectangle et non ça fait 3 1
2 3 1 bahreïn
on est à quelques principes du oui j'ai
raison [ __ ] [ __ ] regarde à la baisse
comme faisant encore 3 et pc ok moi je
moi je suis pas contre toi hein je veux
vraiment un conte le réussissant à ok ok
ok ok
c'est tellement minable pas bien
apprécié à nous il ya une chose qui est
sûre
oui quand je vous ai regardé faire c'est
que des fois je trouvais qu'il y avait
des petits ce qui était pas mal mais
elle elle est complètement des centres
et la tête 1 attend qu'un cycle élire sa
mère regarde aller pas aligné avec
l'élastique
oui d'accord donc je pense que quoi
qu'on fasse on va être emmerdé par l
donc moi je propose de l'aligner comme
ça c'est une proposition ferme et moi
j'aimerais pas de vous rencontrer des
gens qui sont carrément prêt à en faire
une vidéo bande-annonce cela me met
vraiment la tête à tête à nolife abano
la finale du simple la banlieue imagine
on va l'appliquer des gens qui
participent à la normale en lice ont
voulu en garde
alors moi je m'en prends une dans chaque
oreille suivant on regarde on peut avoir
l'impression que ça prend forme et en
même temps il ya plein de trucs qui vont
pas franchement ça prend mais mais mais
mais on est quand même plus proche de
tout ce qu'on a pu voir jusqu'à un art
absolument entre la crotte de vanille
puis mes petites plaques d'égout 8 je
garde l'idée de départ de il faut
tâtonner quattro incroyable ça c'est
très joli avec la petite cheminée leur
binôme est le seul succès que mg bid et
il nous arrangerait plus ici ouais a
maintenant prête à faire ce déplacement
complet ça ça lb non ça a non non non
parce qu'en fait le principe de
l'élastique c'est qu'ils touchent
toujours le celui à qui il est attaché
eh bah ouais comment on pourrait alors
moi ce stade serait déjà tellement fière
de moi que je laisserais comme ça oui en
disant que c'est une volonté de ma part
d'avoir mis de cheminer sur les si tu
vois un parti-pris absolument assumer
nous et c'est assumé huit erreurs oui
oui vous croyance erronée mais de penser
que je mets pas le bout des doigts que
je suis confort maintenant je suis un
anticonformiste a aussi une anarchiste
sinon côte qu'on fasse comme ça faisait
mais voilà nous avons un cube je crois
que c'est super motivant table mais je
veux que ça s'arrête
non mais en vrai ce qui m'a aidé c'était
de pouvoir le manipuler aventure à vos
armes et vos armoires c'est
impressionnant et coule et que si tu
veux je te laisse le plaisir d'essayer
de comme dans tout bon casse tête quand
on fait un sang soit capable de faire
l'autre sens essaye de refaire le robot
je te jure que ça peut bien se passer
c'est plus facile ça non il se remet pas
tout seul de mai
quasiment propose-t-il sca jeanne soin
de terminer à la il ya quand même tombé
de 10 mètres de haut viens on voit que
c'est un robot alors du mal
bogut ce but de henry ça c'est la petit
monde est pas bon non j'ai le petit
bourg
non c'est pas le petit renne en face à
ces aides ben c'est lui qui dit dont ben
alors qu'est-ce qui fait le beau des
pôles ce qui qui les attend mais [ __ ]
ah et puis là on est presque monde ça va
être la petite jambes
eh ben voilà regardez-moi ça bravo a nié
les faits sabia extras aux biens
fabuleux comme d'habitude on vraiment là
pardon j'avais ça soit pas ça pas dans
le décor du coup et ça vous a plu
la crise impacte vachement bien et ben
moi je vais en faire plein des comme ça
encore cet été c'est vrai ben ali
n'avait pas prévu de faire suis là
aujourd'hui mais du coup comme tu étais
là et puis après jamais arrivé je trouve
ça plus sympa le robot merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à mon instagram ou à son
instagram ou à sa chaîne youtube wat sa
chaîne youtube gardant le contact durant
l'été mais moi je n'ai vidéo en ce
moment sur ce secteur
et ça c'est sympa et ça c'est sympa
c'est divertissant d'as à pied avait
beaucoup un mois je marche dans la rue
on me dit ça nous plaît mais ouais bien
sûr mais dix fois moins coûteux moi je
passe ma vie dessus
j'aurais fait à regarder la vidéo si
vous a plu à très bientôt mercredi
prochain au plus tard ciao ciao